en el último video aprendimos un poco
sobre
aldeidos sobre aldeidos y vimos que
tienen la estructura general donde
tienes un grupo carbonilo unido a algún
tipo de cadena de carbonos o me parece
que en la forma más simple esto puede
ser solo un hidrógeno y luego
definitivamente Tendrán por lo menos un
hidrógeno Unido al carb en el grupo
carbonilo esto era un aldeido ahora muy
estrechamente relacionada a un aldeido
hay un tipo de molécula llamada
ceona dibujemos un par de cetona solo
para hacer las cosas claras Y luego
pensaremos sobre la diferencia entre una
acetona y un aldeido esto de aquí
ch3 ch
3 un carbono justo aquí esto de aquí es
una acetona y me dirás oye eso es muy
similar a un aldeido tengo un grupo
carbonilo en
ambos esto de aquí es un grupo carbonilo
esto de aquí es un grupo carbonilo
déjame escribir esto
carbonilo tenemos un grupo carbonilo en
ambos tenemos una cadena de carbonos por
aquí esta de aquí podría ser una cadena
general de carbonos aquí tenemos un
grupo metilo Así que cómo es esto
diferente y creo que te darás cuenta que
es esta parte que no he resaltado aún en
un aldeido hay dos maneras de pensar en
un aldeido m podrías decir que mira el
grupo carbonilo está al final de una
cadena de carbonos por lo que lo
siguiente arriba será un hidrógeno o
podrías decir que en un aldeido tienes
por lo menos un hidrógeno unido a un
carbono carbonílico y la manera en la
que recuerdo eso es que tienes un
hidrógeno ahí y en la acetona no lo
tienes el grupo carbonilo está
incrustado en la cadena de carbono está
unido a por lo menos está unido a un
carbono en cada lado por Aquí tienes un
carbono y la manera en la que recuerdo
la diferencia Y esto es solo un poco de
nemotecnia para memorizarlo aldeido se
escribe con h aldeido se escribe con h
hay una H justo aquí y un aldeido tiene
un hidrógeno unido a este carbono ahora
que por lo menos hemos entendido
razonablemente lo que es una acetona
nombremos algunas solo para
familiarizarnos esto de aquí es la
acetona más simple posible y se llama
aona más bien Ese es su nombre común
otra manera tradicional o común de
nombrar una acetona es nombrar cada uno
de estos grupos y es parecido a como
nombramos los éteres pero en lugar de
escribir la palabra éter al final
escribimos la palabra
aquí tenemos un grupo metilo y tenemos
otro grupo metilo así que tenemos dos
grupos metilo justo aquí esto sería
ditil
seona esta de aquí es dimetilcetona y
luego si quieres la manera sistemática
de nombrarlas solo mira la cadena más
grande que es 1 dos 3es carbonos por lo
que es
prop propa Y en lugar de llamarla
propano quitamos esa O de ahí y la
llamamos
propa
nona eso nos dice que esto de aquí es
una
acetona y tienes que saber dónde se
encuentra el doble enlace y de hecho
para propanona no tienes que
especificarlo porque si sabes que es una
acetona sabes que tiene que tener un
carbono a cada lado del grupo carbonilo
por lo que de hecho no tienes que ni
siquiera especificar Dónde está el grupo
carbonilo pero si hubieras querido
podrías decir bien el grupo carbonilo
está en el carbono dos No importa De qué
lado empieces a contar estará en el
carbono dos
pero el dos es algo opcional para la
propanona hagamos otro más digamos que
tenemos una molécula que se
ve
así la manera tradicional de nombrarla
dirías en este extremo de la acetona
tengo uno dos tres carbonos en ese
extremo tengo tres
carbonos eso es un
grupo
proo y en este otro lado de la acetona
justo Aquí tengo solo un carbono eso es
un grupo
meo después solo los nombrarás y los
nombras de acuerdo al incremento de
tamaño en su cadena tamaño de molécula o
tamaño de grupo en este escribiste metil
Primero
me
til porque es solo un carbono Entonces
esto es
metil
pro pil cetona metil propil
ceona Esta es la manera tradicional o
común a menudo la manera más usada para
nombrar esta molécula pero la manera
sistemática de nombrarla observa la
cadena de carbonos más larga y dices
bien tengo 1 2 3 4 c carbonos por lo que
será pent Y luego quieres empezar a
numerar la para que el carbono
carbonílico tenga el menor número
posible Entonces quieres empezar a
numerar en en el lado derecho 1 dos 3
cuat y C esto de aquí hemos dicho que el
prefijo será pent es
pentan Y en lugar de decir que es
pentano decimos que es
pentan na Y para especificar dónde está
el grupo carbonilo dices que es dos
Esta es dos pentanona e incluso puedes
verla escrita de esta manera
pen
tan dos
ona cualquiera de estas sería correcta
veamos un ejemplo un poco más
complicado digamos que teníamos algo que
se veía
así tenemos una molécula que se ve así
Sí y déjame Añadir algunos cloros por
aquí Qué sería
Esto bueno nuestra cadena más larga una
vez más es este cicloexano
1 2 3 4 5 6 carbonos y solo nombraré
esto de manera sistemática y entre más
complicado se vuelve algo más
sistemático la gente lo quiere nombrar
si tenemos seis bonos aquí y están en
una cadena esto es
ciclo
heano pondrías la o ahí si este grupo
carbonilo no estuviera ahí pero ya que
lo está la llamaremos
ciclohexanona esto de aquí nos dice que
la nombremos
ciclo
hexanona y luego en un adillo como este
Esto será implícitamente el carbono
número uno si este es el carbono número
uno y queremos numerar en una dirección
de tal manera que los siguientes grupos
tengan el menor número posible queremos
hacer esto el carbono 2s esto es do do
diclorociclohexano
es
dos
dioro
ciclohexanona
Ahora hay dos más y solo te mostraré
esto porque estos tienden a ser
conocidos con sus nombres comunes solo
quiero mostrártelo
rápidamente una es esta molécula de
aquí donde tenemos un grupo metilo en
este lado
ch3 y por acá
tenemos un anillo de benceno
tenemos un anillo de
benceno aquí ahora Esa primera acetona
bastante simple que vimos la llamamos
acetona y entonces el nombre común aquí
es de hecho derivado de la acetona en
lugar de llamarla acetona Porque no solo
tiene un grupo metilo aquí se llama
ao Y en lugar de acetona es
acetofenona porque tenemos este grupo
fenilo este anillo de benzeno de ahí
aceto
Noa la cual es una molécula bastante
común y verás que se refieren a ella de
esta manera ahora otra que podrías ver
de vez en cuando y solo quiero
presentr es una molécula que se ve
así que tiene dos anillos de benzeno en
ella se ve así Y esta es benso fenona
Ben
so
fea solo quería presentarte los nombres
comunes de estas últimas dos pero en
general creo que tienes una idea decente
en este
de cómo nombrar al menos las cadenas más
simples tanto con sus nombres comunes
por ejemplo propil o metil propil cetona
o dos
pentanona y estos son los ejemplos más
típicos O tal vez los más
sencillos